[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's
bring in peter schrager for the nfl
network good morning football
and foxsports.com senior national writer
do you believe that that uh i believe
it's a
it's a combination of things here they
have a new coach they had a new thing
and i
sometimes you see reports out there and
ian's probably spot on
the way it's worded is always
interesting does that come from
other teams saying we're lighting up the
phones for carson wentz or does that
come from
philadelphia throwing some crumbs out
there to the other team saying hey
um maybe you should be calling on this
guy it's always interesting this week
when everyone has all eyes on these
quarterbacks
when a team comes out of nowhere from
left field and says yeah we're getting
calls too
are you now you got the kings of leon as
your backdrop there on this zoom call
yeah i mean look when you love a band as
much as i love the follow will brothers
and uh i ca you guys are talking about
the kings of leon like they're the
rolling stones of the beatles come on
guys
so you had that up before you heard me
talking about the kings of leon
is that right yeah every day all day
i've got a kings of leon background
wait you're not kings of leon fan i am i
like that
actually true story i was at a super
bowl one year in dallas and i saw sam
bradford walk in with the kings of leon
and i saw about 500 women the ages 21 to
age 35 just like fall over them
for a moment there i was slightly
jealous of all four four of those guys
yeah but what's sam bradford doing with
the kings of leon oklahoma
connection oklahoma guys sam bradford i
think you know bradford not
not the best nfl career but he was he
was pretty popular that night
he got paid that was when it was i never
ha understood this peter
that you have these rookie contracts
where you got all this money up front
and you weren't proven and then they
finally realized boy this really sounds
stupid
we're paying all these guys 35 40
million dollar signing bonus
when they haven't proven so we've added
even more pressure on them when they
come in
to be great it was i think bradford was
actually the last one to get it but
um or is it amongst that crew but those
guys yeah cam newton i think might have
been the last he got like three nights
i remember i remember jake locker got a
big deal
and walked away from the game and you're
like how could jake locker walk away
from the games
jake locker made it made 80 million
dollars on his rookie contract jake
locker's good
uh how do the texans handle this can
they trade desean watson
they can absolutely they can i've spoken
to a lot of people around the league
and to amanda and people are calling the
texans i mean teams that you're hearing
rumor they're calling the texans
and nick casario the new front office
chief in the gm
who signed a very handsome six-year
contract
to make him one of the highest paid jams
in the league is telling teams like
we're not interested in talking like
straight up like robotic we're not
talking so
we can speculate all we want there is a
confidence in that building they can
make this right
however from the watson side and you
hear this from the other teams too
there's a belief that he might take this
all the way to training camp
and say i'm not putting that uniform on
again until i get traded who's got the
stomach for this
is it watson where he's going to say i'm
so upset with the franchise that they
didn't lean on me for any
counsel or guidance or my
recommendations on the coach in the gm
or is it the team side that says listen
new coach new gm
let's at least talk this out before we
go to those drastic measures because you
know this desean watson
those kind of players don't just show up
every other year that's a franchise
player and no matter who they had a
quarterback it probably won't be as good
as that young man
it was five months tomorrow when he
signed this contract extension
he was thrilled he wrote a letter he
thanked the owner he thanked everybody
changed my life everything's great and
then this is they had already traded
deandre hopkins so
what happened where desean watson went
i don't want to be here anymore
chronologically i think you nail it or
you say wait he already traded yet
because everyone says they traded his
best receiver no no they had already
traded his best receiver that wasn't
some shock
the things that i've heard this is not
about nick casario this isn't even about
uh the trade of hopkins this is more
about the owner
and cal mcnair and desean watson
apparently had a conversation
and from everything i hear this
conversation was like you are going to
be a very important part
of our next hires once bill o'brien was
fired whether it be the coach in the gm
watson's voice might have been out there
he might have said something
he might have suggested names those
names were not brought in for interviews
they
they hired nick casario without asking
desean watson's approval which
i think historically would never ask a
player's approval on the gm
and then with the coaches no robert sala
interview
a few few other names weren't
interviewed and they didn't even get him
in the door and
from another team dan i thought this was
interesting in another year you might
say okay well come on deshawn like
whatever
do you know how easy it is to just
interview the guys he recommended and do
it on zoom yeah it's a two-hour zoom
two hours you check the box even if you
have no interest in what he says
if you told him you were going to listen
to him and he said hey you got to
interview robert sala and that's just an
example of a name
two hours on zoom with robert saw it
might have been a waste of silence time
but what's the
what's the expense just do it they
didn't do it first of all they never
should have
given him that power because all these
marquee quarterbacks don't have that
power and you're going to give it to
deshaun watson he's got a no trade clock
like the texans created this and then
all of a sudden
it's like wait a minute what happened
here that this house is on fire
well you helped start the fire there and
now deshawn watson wants to run out of a
burning building
and i mean look again the verbiage we're
talking about ian's report about wence
you go to with watson's it's he's
requesting a trade and the next day i
came out and i got some slack from
from people because i was like is he
requesting a trade or demanding a trade
because
are you requesting a divorce that
doesn't have the same impact as i'm
demanding a divorce
so what happens with watson over the
next few months will be interesting
because once
free agency is over once the draft is
over their options get really limited
then it's does this guy have the stomach
because
there's a new cba and a new cba they can
find you all they want
for missed practices you don't get that
money back you can't get that money back
that's part of the new cba so he could
be fined up to two million dollars
if he doesn't show up and contractually
he's there not only for this huge
extension but for three years of the
franchise tag too
does he have the stomach to really ride
this out peter schrager is host of nfl
network's good morning football which
airs monday through friday they start at
7
eastern and uh nfl network providing
more than
70 hours of live super bowl coverage
including
eight and a half hour edition of nfl
game day morning good
god super bowl sunday at nine eastern
with our buddy rich eisen
there hasn't been a buzz about this and
i don't know how much of this
is that the media is not there peter
but if we were there because the story
lines if we look at them
um don't really have to do with the
super bowl as much as they do
scotty miller says he's the fastest
player in the nfl
whoa we broke that story by the way uh
we played the clip yep you have deshawn
watson drama
carson wentz situation a coach gets
hired
eric the enemy does not brady belichick
so the game itself even though we're
it's about
brady and patrick mahomes and if brady
wins one more then mahomes will never
catch him and if he has
you know his second super bowl he's
gonna catch him
where is the buzz on this game for a
game that should be great
but it doesn't feel like it's there it's
so true you say that and
you know we're on the nfl network three
hours every morning and i feel it we're
not there
so the buzz usually you have the
wall-to-wall coverage and there's the
scenics of tampa and everyone's walking
around it's not there and that is
because of the pandemic 100
because of the pandemic that doesn't
feel like we're getting the same buzz
because this game
is awesome it has every storyline we
could have ever wanted i mean
we turned tom brady and jared goff into
a super bowl bonanza we could certainly
turn tom brady and patrick mahomes
there's two amazing story lines here
it's mahomes and the chiefs going for
back to back which hasn't been done
since 0304 and then it's brady
brady is such an amazing story to do
this in first year
but to your point i wonder if it's more
hypothetical right now with
what will this mean legacy wise what
does this do for the great debate at the
bar
five years from now how do we look back
on this super bowl as far as if it was a
passing of the torture of brady
stiff-arming mahons but right now like
today on the show i'll be candid with
you
i was talking about the offensive line
injuries from the chiefs
and how remembers is in and now you're
doing andrew wiley
right like i'm getting bored of myself
talking about offensive line play and i
can sense it
and i think it's just gonna have to be
one of those deals where we're not there
on the ground but come sunday
and you see jpp and shaq barrett blowing
up patrick mahomes
and you're saying wow we got a game here
and brady's got the ball in the fourth
quarter we got a game here
the hype might not be there but this
game is going to deliver would you
rather have
brady's career or what mahomes career
could possibly be
i mean that's why that's a great
question like you're taking the unknown
which is on this incredible toured pace
or what we do know and it's still kind
of going
i would take brady i would take brady i
would take brady because
of the accomplishments over the great
great time span i don't know what
happens to my homes 10 years down the
road but i'd be
hard-pressed to think he's going to do
seven super bowls in 14 afc or nfc
championship games in 20 years
i'm going to remind you of this question
in like 10 years from now i know let's
just let's just hope the two of us are
doing the same exact thing in 10 years
uh the uh rams lions trade um
we had aaron donald on and uh in fact
we're going to play that interview
coming up a little bit but
he said he was shocked that uh should he
have been shocked
that the rams sent the jared goff to the
lines and they got matthew stafford
i've got to be careful here because i've
got relationships on both sides
i'll just say it now we're five days
removed mcveigh was over golf
it was done but when did that happen
peter was it after the niners game
no it happened this year and it wasn't
necessarily all jared's doing like this
i think the defense being the being the
leader in this thing mcveigh not being
able to do the same things that leflore
was able to do with rogers and what he's
watching uh you know other teams do and
nothing against jerry personally jared
goff went 21-26 through a touchdown pass
in lambeau field with nine fingers i
thought that was pretty good and pretty
tough
but once they got to this point it was
either do we try to rebuild this thing
or do we just move on for both of us
and mcveigh wanted to move on and once
stafford came into his life and when i
say came into his life it meant the
thought of stafford and the
and the wonder of what he can do with
his arm strength and how smart and how
cerebral
it was over and mcveigh made the call
and it's a business
and i think sean is going to be
respectful to jared and
he'll also be unapologetic that he
believes that this team had run its
course with jared goff and
he wanted matt stafford golf can make
him look foolish if goff goes on
to have this incredible career in
detroit or even anywhere else he ends up
he can make mcveigh look wrong but as as
someone from the ram side told me are
are we living or are we existing they
want to live is stafford that much of an
upgrade over golf
not my decision they think so no but i'm
curious if you think so
i don't i don't i don't think he's a
huge
upgrade but i think for what they've
been through over the last few years
with for sean and jared to come to this
point of course it's an upgrade
but as far as objectively who do i want
with my quarterback a 25 year old guy
who's been to a super bowl
or a 33 year old guy coming off injuries
who's never won a playoff game you can
make the argument for the former
yeah i i think detroit did well in this
deal
pete i i really do stafford wanted to
get a soft landing they wanted to trade
him
okay how many places can we we send you
to felt like it was going to be the
niners or is going to be the rams
and i thought that you you got a guy who
can potentially be a franchise
quarterback already under contract
and he got some draft picks here so i
thought detroit did okay
they did all right here's the here's the
rub on it carolina offered a really good
package
including a top 10 pick and from what
i'm hearing they threw teddy
bridgewater's name in there a future
first round pick and
people around the league are like how do
you not take carolina's offer because
then if you take carolina's offer you
get
the seventh overall pick which is the
lions pick the eighth overall pick which
is the panthers pick you get teddy
bridgewater to be your bridge
quarterback
and the lions folks would tell you we
like jared goff believe it or not guys
hello like jared goff was a piece of
this trade and
to take on jared goff and then also get
two first-round picks that's a bonanza
if you actually believe in jared goff
which they say they do
this uh i'll end with this the haircut
story with the chiefs
felt like it was if i'm going to have an
onion headline
and you know close shave chiefs you know
get caught
with uh barber with covid like
the fact imagine if patrick mahomes is
in the chair
because i'm surprised he wasn't at the
front of the line hey
patrick you go in you've got other
meanings here if patrick mahomes is in
the chair he's not practicing this week
pete i mean incredible and it's like
daniel kilgore is a backup center slash
guard so everyone makes a joke and it's
like i
killed if mahomes gets in that chair
he's out every day of practice with an
offensive line
he's not exactly familiar with and it's
a huge story line but it is 2020 summed
up and
um adam schefter sending four tweets out
about a barber
on the day it just tells you where we're
at these days
and i love shefty and it just shows you
and the guy only delivers
his news and pearls and that's what we
were tweeting about this week that's
2021
in a nutshell and your pick is
cheats all right i mean was that a
confident chiefs or just
oh no on paper with the barber story
with the offensive line with the game
being played in tampa with brady on the
other sideline with that defensive line
it
it's very easy to want to take the bucks
but i can't pick against my homes
i can't pick against brady like i'd
never bet against him
i would until i see it we've seen it
he's lost three super bowls yeah but you
know that
i can't blame him against philadelphia
no he threw for
500 yards and they didn't even punt like
you know that's that's on belichick but
you know the game against the giants in
both of those games you know the
defensive line
just pounded him and if the chiefs are
able to do that
then the chiefs are going to win this
game but on the same token though
it's like mahomes so many games this
year we're close and then on third and
six we'll hit tyreek for seven yards and
put the game away
i've in all of my years covering the
sport
this guy mahomes finds a way in every
single game
to get the w at the end i can't pick
against them here
yeah but it's weird how they get bored
or they need degree of difficulty peter
like yeah they've won 25 of 26 games
with him however it happens it happens
uh hey great to talk to you and uh
thanks again
yeah yeah thank you buddy that's uh
peter schrager he's a popular member of
that good morning football team